[Music]
this video will show active learning
using worksheets in a large interactive
physics class it will discuss why and
how to use worksheets in lecture the
class is one section of an algebra based
introductory course that has typically
750 students enrolled in three sections
when entering the lecture hall the
students pick up a worksheet that
contains most of the activities for the
lecture in this example the worksheet is
designed to support an understanding of
electric circuits the class starts with
a relatively brief introduction the
students are reminded of what has been
discussed so far and some context for
the class is provided remember this
example from last class with the two
identical bulbs and there was a switch
across one of the light pipes across
Part B the introduction ends with a
motivation for the first worksheet task
and then students are directed to start
working on the first worksheet problem
and use the definition of power and our
circuit rules to predict what happens
when this switch students are typically
given seven to eight minutes to work
during which they are encouraged to
discuss solution strategies with their
peers and my approach the worksheets
actually the second exposure of the
students to the new material the first
exposure to new content happens in the
pre-class reading assignment I tell my
students that I expect them only to know
the basic definitions and perhaps try to
understand the basic concepts without
really expecting them to know everything
in depth at this point
typical worksheets contain conceptual
questions they contain relatively
difficult problem questions that where
the students have to use some important
procedural knowledge
as free body diagrams or graphs or
circuit diagrams things like that in
contrast to work problems in which I
just go through a solution the worksheet
activities give the students time to
work on the problem in class at their
own pace
lecture TA and I visit with student
groups we will look at that worksheet
see where students get stuck we will ask
them whether have difficulties if for
instance several student groups have the
same difficulties we can interrupt the
activity and give hints to the entire
class having a teaching assistant is
valuable in such a large class the
lecture ta answers student questions
during worksheet activities and after
class he or she can alert the instructor
to technical problems such as when the
writing is too small or the microphone
not loud enough he or she can carry a
microphone and repeat student questions
the instructor missed or let the
instructor know when a solution is not
clear and needs more explanation the
lecture ta can also give important
feedback after class until the
instructor which activity motivated the
students and which things are now clear
or still unclear to the students I give
the students roughly seven to eight
minutes based on experience for a
worksheet problem and it turns out that
in that time roughly two-thirds of the
students will have finished the activity
I often use clicker questions to help me
with the timing so for instance I ask
students to answer a follow-up clicker
question and from the numbers that the
clicker shows me I can tell how many
students have answered the question
so I aim for roughly two-thirds of the
class to finish
work sheet tasks should be difficult
enough to encourage peer discussions
there is little value in having work
sheet problems that the students can
quickly solve on their own because not
all students are able to finish the
solution there's of course the concern
that the weaker students become
disengaged however I often tell my
students that they are not expected to
finish a solution that it's important
just to think very hard about how to
approach a solution and how to approach
a problem and that way they have thought
about a problem enough so that when I
show the solution they can compare their
approach to mine so even if they don't
finish they get a lot of out of the
worksheet activities asking a closely
related clicker question is a good way
to initiate the follow-up and bring the
attention back to the instructor and be
smaller than CNT perhaps take another
minute and discuss this with your
neighbors that disagree with your answer
and see if you can convince your
neighbors
[Music]
the clicker question and peer discussion
usually takes three to five minutes a
detailed solution with discussion
follows that can take up to ten minutes
so a complete worksheet activity with
follow-up can take anywhere between 10
and 30 minutes depending on complexity
and difficulty in the 80 minute physics
class for worksheet problems are
discussed on average new this I 2 is
equal to I 3 and so are these greater or
smaller than I 1 the follow-up is an
essential part of a worksheet activity
the students had spent some time
thinking hard about a solution and they
want to know now if their way if their
approach is the correct one and so in
order for them to be able to follow my
solution and to compare their thoughts I
need to go over the solution in detail
steps and I need to take my time with it
so I usually write on a document camera
when I do this and when I explain rather
than showing the solution you just on a
PowerPoint slide I use PowerPoint only
for introductions and summaries right so
the last steps are I can do it with you
here so you know that let's say you get
I don't grade my worksheets some
instructors do but in any case it's very
important that the students get to keep
their worksheets the students use them
as important Studies tools because the
worksheets contain the most important
activities for each lecture worksheets
are a great way to increase students
learning in lecture they allow students
to work at their own pace and allow the
instructor to monitor students progress
and provide immediate feedback and help
worksheets are not difficult to design
and are much appreciated by students
[Music]
you